First of all I wanted to feel reasonably confident that I knew what I was talking about.
In private,  I've liked learning and talking about physics ever since I was a student.
In fact, talking about the subject
as soon as one has a general idea of the notions and the language is a great way to learn things.
Since more experienced people can then correct your misconceptions, and you really learn through that process.
But referring to physics in my research or organizing public activities surrounding physics is
claiming a good deal more competence than might be required for conversations, so that took longer.
The fact that the number theory community tends to be a pretty tough minded crowd
was probably part of the reason for my silence.
They're not easily impressed by ideas unless you show that you can do something definite with them.
So I needed to have theorems, results and pretty concrete directions
before admitting that physics was an important part of my thinking.
I sometimes like to compare theorems and definite results to money in the bank.
Then when you're just describing ideas and general philosophy
you're using that money, maybe even going into debt.
so then you need to get back to proving theorems.
I should stress that I think this kind of skepticism on the part of the community is a good thing overall
Meeting the challenge of skeptics is definitely an important part of organizing one's thoughts thereby making them more precise and useful
even if it's difficult sometimes.
Perhaps a more weighty aspect of the decision
to admit the influence of physics openly now is a certain sense of scientific obligation.
To put it in slightly grandiose terms,
it's clear we're at a place in scientific history where
the interplay of ideas between physics and number theory is quite important and
young people, especially energetic young people, should be paying attention to it.
There are many indications,
such as the work on motives and Feynman diagrams, all the new work on conformal field theory
and modular forms, arithmetic aspects of Chern-Simons theory, S-duality, and the Langlands program;
there are many, many others.
I feel strongly that the interface has
important insight to offer to people working in arithmetic geometry
but also to people working in fundamental physics especially quantum field theory and strings.
Even if I personally say some foolish things while advertising the connections
I feel like I shouldn't be hiding from a serious discourse, in private as well as in public.